With the long-running debate over mandatory
minimum sentences over the past couple of
decades, it’s easy to forget that judges
and juries often have a great deal of discretion
when it comes to imposing criminal sentences
for individual crimes.
So while we can’t say what single crime
will definitively result in the longest prison
sentence, we can look at the crimes that have
resulted in the records for the longest prison
sentences in the United States and around
the globe.
To begin with, the longest prison sentence
ever imposed was 141,078 years.
It was given in 1989 in Thailand to Chamoy
Thipyaso and each of her seven accomplices
for defrauding more than 16,000 Chinese investors
as a part of a massive Ponzi scheme.
(see: What is a Ponzi Scheme and Why Do We
Call It That?)
On the other hand, in the U.S. the longest
sentence for some form of corporate fraud
was only 845 years.
This was handed down in 2000 to Sholam Weiss,
for his role in the collapse of National Heritage
Life Insurance.
By contrast, Bernie Madoff was only given
150 years for his 2009 conviction of defrauding
thousands in a multi-billion dollar Ponzi
scheme.
The second and third longest prison sentences
(for any crime), globally, were given to Jamal
Zougam (42,924 years) and Emilio Suárez Trashorras
(49,922 years) for their roles in the 2004
train bombings in Madrid.
As for the longest prison term imposed in
the United States, it was given in 1994 to
the Oklahoma child rapist Charles Schott Robinson
who was convicted of six counts of rape garnering
him 5,000 years in prison each- a whopping
30,000 year sentence.
Also in Oklahoma, Darron B. Anderson and Allan
W. McLaurin each had in the thousands of years
ranges of prison time imposed for the kidnapping,
robbery and rape of an elderly woman.
Anderson was initially only sentenced to 2,200
years, but upon his second trial (he appealed
and won a new one), that second jury imposed
a sentence of 11,250 years.
McLaurin was initially sentenced to 21,250
years, but the appellate court reduced it
to a mere 500 years.
In 1981, after killing his wife, mother-in-law
and an unlucky visitor to their home, Dudley
Wayne Kyzer was sentenced to 10,000 years,
along with a couple of life sentences, by
an Alabama court.
He has been up for, and denied, parole nine
times.
The longest prison sentence imposed in Australia
was given to Martin Bryant in 1996 for the
Port Arthur, Tasmania massacre where he killed
35 and injured 23 others.
His sentence included 1,035 years without
parole plus 35 life sentences, one for each
life he took.
Large prison sentences continue to be imposed
today.
Cleveland’s Ariel Castro received, as part
of a plea deal in 2013, life plus 1,000 years
for the kidnapping, rape and murder (for the
intentional inducing of miscarriages) of three
women over a 10-plus year period.
He hanged himself in prison in 2013.
The infamous Aurora theater shooter, James
Holmes, was given 12 life sentences plus an
additional 3,318 years in 2015 for killing
12 people and injuring another 70.
Yet another extremely lengthy sentence doled
out in 2015 was given to Billy Godfrey of
Rolla, Missouri.
His punishment included 35 life sentences
for convictions of 35 counts of statutory
sodomy.
His victims, assaulted between 1995 and 1999,
were between the ages
of 8 and 13 at
the
time
of Godfrey’s crimes.